okay
hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
and i see we have all kinds of questions
saved up here
ah gosh let's start
okay here's one from architect
how do glaciers form
i don't think there's anything that
difficult to understand about that i
think
it's just
when water gets cold enough it freezes
into ice
now
uh
it's a complicated story because
ice
comes in many different forms so
whenever you have a solid
uh the different kinds of solids there
are crystalline solids and there are
amorphous solids so in a crystalline
solid all the atoms or molecules of the
material are lined up in some regular
array so for example in salt table salt
sodium chloride
the uh
the the sodiums and chlorines are
arranged in this kind of cubic lattice
um
that a very very regular lattice like
that in diamond there's another
particular arrangement of the carbon
atoms in graphite a different
arrangement in which things that tend to
be in sheets
in ice
there are different forms of ice that
correspond to different possible
arrangements of the of the water
molecules so for example in the most
standard form of ice
um they are hexagonal it's a hexagonal
array of positions of water molecules so
for example the reason that that
snowflakes
tend to have a basically hexagonal form
is because
on the inside the little water molecules
are arranged in this hexagonal grid
now in fact when snowflakes have formed
it's kind of complicated sometimes
snowflakes form is just a simple
hexagonal plate but usually they have
arms hanging off them and that that
happens because when when the snowflake
is growing there are places on the
snowflake where a new piece of ice is
added every time water vapor condenses
into ice
it releases a certain amount of heat but
the reason for that is this
in the gas phase of water
where it's steam
the molecules are running around very
fast it makes a gas in the solid the
molecules are just locked in place
in their regular array
so in order for one to go from the steam
where all the molecules are running
around to the to the solid where they're
locked in place you have to release some
of that energy so there's there's the
things are running around they have high
energy each one has lots of kinetic
energy um but then they they're somehow
they're they're pulled together enough
that they sort of lock in place into a
crystal
and in order to when they lock in place
into a crystal that that releases a
certain amount of energy which then
becomes sort of heating up of that local
region of the crystal so what tends to
happen is little collection of water
molecules get together they attach as a
piece of ice somewhere on the growing
crystal
they heat up
that part of the crystal because they're
losing all the kinetic energy that they
used to have running around in a gas
and they're they're they're losing that
and they're sort of diffusing it to the
rest of the crystal
but then that means that there's a
little local heating of the crystal at
that place and so that means that when a
piece of ice has been added at a
particular place it's less likely that
another piece of ice will be added
quickly at that same place it has to
wait for the kind of heat to diffuse
away otherwise it isn't cold enough for
another piece of ice to be attached
there and so that phenomenon is kind of
a local growth inhibition where things
grew
just now they don't grow
at the next moment
and that's what leads to this kind of
dendritic structure this tree-like
structure because what's happening is
something grew out on this on this piece
of the tree but it couldn't it didn't
grow in a place where it's already been
accreted but where there already have
been ice added and so if you kind of
work that out you can work it out with
one of these little cellular automata
that i'm very
keen on as a very simple model where you
just say you have a grid of a hexagonal
grid of cells and you have black cells
that represent solid and white cells
that represent gas
and you add a black cell at every step
where there's exactly one black cell
adjacent to it on the step before and if
you do that you'll find that you get
these kind of tree-like structures that
look like snowflakes but if you look
kind of inside the snowflake even though
the the boundary has all this kind of
tree-like structure if you look inside
the snowflake all the water molecules in
that idealized model for example are
arranged in a hexagonal grid and the
same is true with sort of the most
standard form of ice
in um
uh
in when ice forms at standard pressure
for example uh it forms into that kind
of hexagonal array
now if you're inside a glacier for
example there's a big weight of ice on
top of some particular part of the
glacier
and so what you can find happens is that
the when when the when things are
freezing there or perhaps it's it's
rearranged as there's more pressure put
on it you'll you'll end up with
something where the the structure of the
ice is different than the structure of
the ice in sort of regular pressure uh
formation of ice and there are many
different phases i think they're like 40
phases of ice that are known that
correspond to different arrangements of
the water molecules inside the piece of
ice and some of them will have different
densities so for example ordinary ice of
the kind i'm describing this hexagonal
kind of ice floats on water i don't
think these other forms of ice float on
water
so that and but
you you don't get to kind of see that
normally because
with ordinary sort of water liquid water
you're you're dealing with something
which has
is that sort of standard pressure deep
in the ocean it'll be at higher pressure
but um uh so so that's uh that's that's
kind of you know these different forms
of ice that exist in glaciers and i
think that's important to the structure
of glaciers that there can be different
forms of of ice there now a question i
don't know the answer to people say
sometimes that
at least some earthquakes
are due to changes in rock in the earth
going from one phase one arrangement of
molecules to make the solid rock to
another phase and that that changes
things like the volume of the rock and
can lead to this sort of discontinuous
change in uh in in well change
that that it can change the produce
these fracture lines in the rock and i
do wonder whether similar kinds of
things happen in glaciers i don't know
whether there are glacier quakes i don't
i don't know the answer to that
um
you know generally what glaciers do
in the terrain
they they make big grooves because
they're kind of just that you know
they're they're heavy things and they're
sort of pushing down uh uh presumably to
end in the ocean and so on um and the
the what tends to happen is that the
when you have a landscape that has lots
of valleys lots of valleys get formed by
these glaciers i suppose what's
happening is okay so so first of all
rivers for example
will gradually erode away the landscape
so if you have um
if you have something like
some fairly soft rock and you have water
flowing through it the river will
gradually take little pieces of the rock
and take them and and sort of drag them
downstream eventually to the to where
the river ends in the ocean and so it's
taking little pieces of rock from uh
from from high up perhaps and mountains
and it's eventually transporting them to
the ocean and wherever it takes out the
rock wherever the river was it's taking
out the rocks so the river will tend to
grind itself deeper and deeper and
deeper into the rock the ultimate
limiting cases things like the grand
canyon for example where the river has
kind of gradually eaten out
pieces of the rock and taken away those
little little particles little sand from
the rock taking that away um leaving
leaving just this kind of groove in the
rock
and you know one thing that happens with
rivers it's kind of complicated is is a
river it normally goes kind of straight
but as soon as it starts going off to
one side as soon as it has a bend then
when when the river water
goes around the bend it will tend to
preferentially
uh uh
extract break the rock down in places
where where the river is bending and so
what that means is you'll get
more and more extreme meanders more and
more extreme versions of the river uh
you know going from side to side
eventually they'll get so extreme that
the that the piece of river will break
off and you get these little islands in
the middle of the river and then they're
multiple multiple pieces of of of river
that go in different on different sides
but in general what happens is that this
sort of river uh
that that's a it's a way that it sort of
um grinds out
uh pieces of rock and i guess glaciers
do sort of the same thing
um sometimes you see all kinds of
strange geological phenomena i mean one
that um
uh is that a glacier when it's kind of
pushing its way down to the ocean it can
push all kinds of sort of crud in front
of it um all kinds of of other pieces of
rock and mud and so on and so you'll see
these funny places like like there's an
island off the coast of massachusetts
called nantucket that has a very
characteristic shape it's a kind of a a
sort of bow-like shape um and uh you
know if you go there the island is very
proud of its shape and you know every
every uh kind of utility cover um has
sort of an image of the of the shape of
the island on it but that shape comes
because it was pushing when there was a
glacier uh from
the the that was pushing
stuff down towards the ocean and it
pushed ahead of the glacier it pushed
all this stuff and that that that formed
this kind of bow-like like shape ahead
of the um
uh
um ahead of the glacier and that's the
stuff that got deposited there and
turned into the island
so all sorts of phenomenal like that
happen
um i don't know uh um
yeah i think i think that's some
um
that's about all i all i have to say
about
formation of glaciers i mean i think um
uh
you know in
there tends to be
in the history of the earth
the earth gets hotter the earth gets
colder
and
that happens
for a variety of reasons some of which
are understood some of which are not
there's a cycle
23 000 years i think
um malankovic cycle i believe um which
is a cycle that has to do with the
earth's orbit around the sun
um
that uh clearly the earth is hotter if
it's closer to the sun and colder if
it's further from the sun
and so
anything that changes that is going to
change the temperature of the earth
also the temperature of the earth has
changed by the temperature of the
surface of the earth is changed by the
earth's atmosphere but to say the first
thing
clearly what what heats the earth is
light from the sun radiation from the
sun mostly visible light um
and uh the actually a spectrum of light
but it's mostly
concentrated in the visible part of the
spectrum
so
that if the if the temperature of the
sun changes or if the amount of
radiation from the sun changes that has
a big effect on the uh the heat on the
temperature of the earth
similarly
if the earth is further away from the
sun it has an effect or closer to the
sun it has an effect
people don't know whether the sun
uh has constant energy output um over
the course of so so the sun is what's
called a main sequence star
and it has over the course of its
lifetime of about 10 billion years or
about halfway through over the course of
its lifetime it will have different
amounts of
of of radiation that it produces
different amounts of heat that it
generates
um we are a g-type star the sun is and i
think let's see it's
i think the sequence is is not very
useful is ob af gkm that's the that's
the sequence of types of stars and those
types of stars have characteristically
different colors different temperatures
different sizes but as the star evolves
through this so-called main sequence of
burning different kinds of right now the
sun is primarily getting its energy by
the fusion of hydrogen atoms to make
helium but at different times in its
history there will be different uh
different uh kinds of
fusion that are dominant in in the sun
but i think the for the last um i don't
know a billion years or so i think the
um uh the it's believed based on models
of stellar of the structure of stars
that um the output the heat output is
probably more or less constant i think
um but so then the question is okay so
how much
how much
temperature reaches the surface of the
earth
and
that depends on how far away the earth
is from the sun it also depends on the
earth's atmosphere
um now i i should say another thing
which is another potential source of
heat on the earth is from inside the
earth i mean the earth i think i
mentioned this other times
the earth is hot inside you drill down
you go down more than 50 miles it'll be
liquid molten core
um and uh it's um and that that heat
inside the earth
about half of it right now in 4.6
billion years after the earth started
about half of it is heat that's still
remnant from when the earth was first
formed when the earth was formed it was
formed from the accretion of lots of of
different things even down at the level
of event of grains of of stuff and maybe
at the level of individual atoms and so
on what were pushed together to make the
earth
and in that process of pushing all that
together there's a certain amount of
there was heat from those things that
was still remained even when the things
were pulled together by gravity and
about half of the internal heat of the
earth is due to that the other half is
due to radioactive elements in the earth
which
are things like uranium um that are
decaying with uh long decay times in the
billions of years
uh and and randomly nuclei of uranium
for example are sort of blowing up into
smaller nuclei and as they do that those
they release a lot of a lot of energy
each one releases quite a lot of energy
and that again heats the the interior of
the earth
and so at times in the history of the
earth volcanoes for example where the
the things from the liquid core of the
earth spurt up into onto the surface can
be important in heating the earth that
that's not the case right now so far as
i know
and the only the only place where you
get to really uh you know sample the
heat of the earth is in geothermal deep
geothermal wells for example that's a
that's a common place where people can
sort of make use of the heat of the
earth i mean i think in you know your
typical kind of geothermal house
uh
house heating and cooling system doesn't
go down very deep and it uses the fact
that in most places on the earth if you
drill down the temperature of the rock
is around 55 degrees fahrenheit at least
that's true in
in sort of temperate latitudes i'm not
completely certain that's true
throughout the earth but the point is
during the year there are places which
get very hot the in the the air gets
very hot the air gets very cold right
now around here i think today it was
like 90 degrees fahrenheit where i am um
and you know it gets down to minus
10 degrees or something fahrenheit at
different times of year so there's a big
variation in the temperature at the
surface but if you go down
inside the soil inside the rock you
don't have to go very deep you only have
to go
i don't know how far it is you know some
number of feet before the variation
through the year is absolutely minimal
and where it's basically constant 55
degrees fahrenheit throughout the year
um that uh that's because of the
conduction of heat through the rock it
doesn't conduct the heat very quickly
and so in the course of the year it
really hasn't kind of the heat or cold
hasn't really diffused deep into the
rock so the constant the temperature is
more or less constant now if you drill
down further you will eventually get to
where the rock starts to get hotter and
hotter um and that's a result of the
heat coming from the center of the earth
and
the when you drill you know a mild deep
for example it's really hot uh when you
drill a couple of miles deep you're
really getting uh sort of huge amounts
of geothermal uh heating um and if you
can
drill down like for example oil oil
wells are often drilling a mile
i think even a couple of miles deep
to get the layers of rock that were laid
down in the carbon first period that
correspond to the deposits of oil that
come from sort of crushed plant matter
from the carboniferous period that's now
turned into oil um you drill down a mile
or two and you can get to these deposits
of that and then you can uh pump the
pump the liquid up up to the surface and
so on and um and get um
uh and get oil out of the earth but when
you're that deep
one thing that's true is things are just
really hot down there so the question is
how do you make use of that heat
and one thing you can do is you pump
water down
and
the water can be cold at the top but by
the time it's been pumped down if you
can get water that's been pumped down
and
then pump it back up again the water you
get when you pump it up will be really
hot
um now it's a non-trivial thing to
arrange sort of all the engineering of
pumping cold water down getting the hot
water up
and uh you know it tends to be the case
there's a huge development of the
engineering of drilling oil wells
and there's sort of a standalone how big
it is it's like this big or something
it's few inches of you know foot across
or something i think is the typical oil
well size and there are millions of such
wells that have been drilled on the
earth by now to try and extract oil from
deposits and lay down the carboniferous
period and so there's lots of technology
for drilling things about that size
which turns out not to be terrifically
easy to pump water down and get other
water back and so on but that's a place
where that's one of the examples of
where the heat of the earth is something
that can be found at the surface if you
build sort of geothermal deep geothermal
wells like that i mean there are places
on the earth like in iceland for example
where the the sort of heat of the earth
is much closer to the surface there are
lots of volcanoes and geysers and things
like that and that's the place where
it's much easier to get geothermal
energy but anywhere on the earth if you
drill down a couple of miles things will
be really hot and you can use that to to
get energy but most of the temperature
of the surface of the earth has is not
to do with what's inside the earth it's
to do with the
with the elimination from the sun and
it's to do with how much of that
illumination gets down to the surface
how much of it is trapped uh between the
the uh how much of it how much of that
illumination heats the surface
and whether the surface when it's hot
will radiate heat back into space so if
the earth had no atmosphere it would be
the case like the moon has no atmosphere
the um uh well it's there isn't an air
to get heated or cooled on the moon but
the surface of the moon just gets really
hot in the day and really cold at night
and
because it's purely
but it's heated by by direct radiation
from the sun but the important other
issue is how much when when the when the
earth gets hot
how much of that heat
is escapes through infrared radiation
going back out of the earth and and one
of the big issues is
that depending on the on what's in the
atmosphere you can have a situation
where visible light comes in
heats the earth but then
when that the the
what comes back out from the heated
earth is infrared radiation at a
different wavelength and that wavelength
can be blocked by for example carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere and that will
prevent that heat from escaping back
into space
so if if if all the all the energy that
came in in light
might heat the earth but then that
energy would escape back into space
then the the total temperature of the
atmosphere would not increase
but if you block it then it does
increase
and so uh now it's a subtle thing
because for example you know when if
there's a big volcanic explosion for
example and it puts a whole bunch of
small particles into the upper
atmosphere that will tend to block the
light of the sun and so it will make
things cold and so for example 65
million years ago when this uh
you know asteroid hit the earth
that um
wiped out well finished off the
dinosaurs
one of the things that happened was that
it it threw all this gunk into the upper
atmosphere of the earth which made the
it made the the uh uh the sky dark uh
throughout the the day as well as night
um and that meant that for a year or two
the surface of the earth got really cold
and that was kind of bad news if you
were a non-cave-dwelling dinosaur or
something um
and so and a cold-blooded reptile uh
type dinosaur but so things like that
you can you know if you put like small
particles into the upper atmosphere of
the earth you'll pull it down because
you just block light from the sun and
for example if right now if we said okay
let's turn the temperature of the earth
down one degree centigrade we can
probably do that
by just putting
little aerosol particles into the upper
atmosphere of the earth whether that's a
good idea is a whole different story
because once you do that you cool down
the whole earth by degrees centigrade
let's say you don't get to make choices
about oh well actually we just want it
hotter here and colder there and so on
and it kind of has to be this big
collective decision to to do that which
is a difficult thing to to to decide to
to go for
but in any case the um uh there's this
question about the formation of glaciers
originally and what happens is that
the the um
the temperature of the earth
varies
and we get periods where there are ice
ages and there are lots of glaciers that
that form as a result of that because
the average temperature goes down there
are other cases where the the earth
heats up
and um
you know for example around the mid
1600s
uh was a period of time when the earth
was considerably colder than it is now
and famously you know lots of rivers
that now are like free-flowing rivers
were at that time sort of frozen over
throughout the year
that time correlated with the absence of
sun spots on the surface of the spa sun
and some people think that there was a
variation of the of the heat produced by
the sun as a result of that i mean
sunspots so when you when you look and
don't look directly at the disc of the
sun but if you can if you can kind of
let it go through a pinhole and and have
some some image of it or something on
the ground or whatever um or you have
looked through some dark enough glass or
something um at the sun uh actually you
can't see those but then naked eye you
can't see sunspots but but if you if you
have an uh an expanded image of the
surface of the sun or you look at the
image that comes from from spacecraft
that are set up to look at the look at
the sun
um you'll see there are these dark spots
on the surface of the sun and at any
given time there are i don't know how
many there are today you know 10 15 dark
spots on the surface of the sun and you
can look you know wolfman alpha has this
data of the number of sunspots um at any
given time and they vary day to day week
to week
and so on and there tends to be an 11
year cycle in the sun where there are uh
times when there's a solar minimum solar
maximum a large number of sunspots large
amount of solar activity smaller amount
of solar activity um that might be
related to the energy output of the sun
uh actual cause of sunspots is they're
essentially
magnetic storms in the outer layers of
the sun the outer layer of the sun is
kind of a plasma like fire um on the on
the earth and there are places where
there are uh kind of
sort of like storms
in in the structure of that of that
outer atmosphere of the sun
um and sometimes there are places where
you know there are
one of the things that people worry
about quite a bit is so-called coronal
mass ejections um the corona is that
atmosphere that surface layer of the sun
in which there are sunspots these
magnetic storms effectively um that show
up as darker spots on the surface of the
sun
and uh
somewhere associated with those there
are sometimes these big blobs
of um
of solar material that just get ejected
into space um and that one of the
results of that is if they kind of get
it thrown in the direction of the earth
they have a lot of radioactivity that
they produce a lot of electromagnetic
activity
and um there's a uh that can have all
kinds of effects on the earth so it's as
if there's a sort of a giant um
uh electrical
thing
that that goes near the earth and when
that happens
it produces
a lot of electrical effects on the earth
i think there's one when was it the
carrington uh
event was i think 1859 if i remember
right um
was a big coronal mass ejection
um where
this sort of big electrical effects
happened on the earth and at that time
you know telegraph wires there were lots
of telegraph wires going around the
world and a bunch of those got huge
voltages induced on them and all sorts
of bad things happened
quite what would happen
in that kind of
event in modern times with satellites
and and so much electrical machinery and
and
systems on the earth is not completely
clear and you know
electrical transformer stations will
probably start blowing up because they
have too much voltage that is induced in
the wires going into them from these uh
electrical effects from the coronal mass
ejection and so on but there are at
least there's at least some warning that
exists today because there are
satellites that watch
um the uh watch the surface of the sun
um and try and uh detect these kinds of
things and we have oh i don't know how
long it is it's um i don't know how fast
these things go maybe
30 minutes maybe more of warning because
these things we get to see what's
happening on the surface of the sun at
the speed of light so it takes eight
minutes for light to go from the sun to
the earth
but so we will see something you know uh
that happens on the surface of the sun
but all of these electrons and protons
and so on that are part of this coronal
mass ejection they're going slower than
the speed of light and so we get to see
what happened before that big blob of
stuff arrives at the earth and has
whatever effects it has
well let's see that was a long answer um
uh
let's see oh gosh there's all kinds of
questions here related to this
um eggy is asking is the order of the
earth constant around the sun or is
there a variation in large time frame
frame can it explain ice ages
yes there are variations on long time
scales
um
and i am not completely remembering what
the origin of all of those is
but the whole structure of of sort of
planetary orbits in the solar system is
pretty complicated i mean the this sort
of simple
high school physics version is
planets
orbit stars and ellipses
in the first approximation they orbit in
circles they're just a constant distance
away from the star but more accurately
they orbit an ellipse which gets some
during the year one time of the year
it's well the there's there's a very
small eccentricity to that ellipse
there's a very small deviation from
being circular so there's a very small
ellipse you can define a circle you just
define circle has a radius you've got
the center of the circle and every point
on the circle is an equal distance from
the center of the circle in an ellipse
the thing is smooshed and so there's a
semi-major axis where it's kind of a
long diameter and well a long radius and
then a semi-minor axis that's the
shorter radius because it's a smooshed
circle and the orbit of the earth is a
smooshed circle and i don't remember its
eccentricity i'm thinking it's like one
part in a thousand but i'm not sure if
that's right um easy to look up in with
alpha um
the uh
uh
and that um but so during the year the
earth is slightly closer to the sun at
one time than it is another time
the axis of that ellipse doesn't move
very much
um in a perfect inverse square or model
of gravity it doesn't move at all
but things happen because of the effects
of of uh planets other than
uh
it's not just the earth and the sun in
the picture even the moon has an effect
but more so jupiter has a substantial
effect other planets have an effect and
the full story of how the orbits of uh
in the solar system work is really
complicated it's complicated enough that
for example we don't really know uh
going back well
certainly i think these days it's a few
hundred million years we still know more
or less which planets were where and
things didn't get no planets got ejected
from the solar system on that time frame
if you go back a billion years or two
billion years much less clear and there
could easily have been extra planets
that just got ejected from the solar
system and so on so the answer is that
there it is the complicated pattern that
the orbit of the earth is complicated
and there are these cycles that um uh
can affect the um
uh certainly the the average distance of
the earth from the sun and so can have
an effect on on the temperature of the
earth
um
the uh
let's see
um
uh
oh my gosh so many
so many questions here
um
oh wow
there's another
lots of questions about lots of
different topics there's a question
about some
uh from aaron about aerial photographs
of ocean waves
all right let's let's talk a little bit
about ocean waves since we're on this
kind of geo
geological oh i don't know earth science
kick here
um
so
i've already seen kind of waves on the
ocean
and waves are just this whole phenomenon
that happen in lots of different
situations you can have waves on a
slinky spring you can have waves on a
string
waves happen whenever there's sort of
whenever you sort of push things in one
direction and there's a force that pulls
them back to being uh to to sort of a
restoring force and then it overshoots
and it goes back it's like a pendulum
swinging back and forth and there are
there are many different forms of waves
in an ocean
there are waves where the water is
pushed up
and as it's pushed up it's pulled more
down by gravity and so it it goes down
but it but as it's pulled down it's sort
of running so fast that it overshoots
and it gets pulled too far down and then
it gets pulled up again and so on if you
were to kind of take a slice through a
typical ocean wave what you find is if
you looked at the actual molecules of
water you'd find they're going in
circles the ocean wave is the the
molecule is going up it's going down
it's coming back in it's it's sort of
going around in a circle now if you look
at the surface of the ocean it seems to
be undulating in in waves but the actual
uh pieces of water
are going in circles inside that wave
now actually there are several different
kinds of wave so on on water there are
so called um
uh let's see deep water waves which are
the main ones you see
in the ocean yes
uh there are surface waves and there are
surface tension waves the surface waves
which are just affecting oh no i'm sorry
i'm sorry the the waves that are that
are the main ocean waves are actually uh
surface waves because they affect
they're just
um
waves where the where the where the
pieces of water are are sort of
circulating at the near the surface of
the water as opposed to uh deep water
waves where it matters what the bottom
of the ocean is like
the the the typical waves you see on an
ocean which are sort of crashing on the
beach
are not ones where it matters what the
what happens at the bottom of the ocean
and and so what what um when when you
see those waves sort of crashing on the
beach one thing that's often surprising
is how random the succession of of kind
of uh wave uh sort of wave arrivals is
they're roughly equally spaced but
they're always you know one wave is
bigger another wave is smaller and so on
and so what causes that well first thing
to know
is that first question is how do the
waves get produced on the ocean they get
produced by wind blowing on the ocean
and sort of ruffling up the surface of
the ocean and so then what you're seeing
is kind of a typically when there's lots
of activity of ocean ocean waves you're
seeing some storm that might have
happened hundreds of miles or more away
um in in the ocean and there are waves
that were generated by that storm and
those waves have been traveling across
the surface of the ocean
until they finally get to the beach
you're at and then they they kind of
break at the beach
now also what you see is as as waves
approach a beach
as the
eventually i mentioned that sort of the
the water is going around in these
circles eventually the circles are too
big to fit in the depth of water that
exists near that beach and so that's why
the waves break they they'll have these
um
they will no longer be just able to sort
of undulate the surface of the water up
and down they'll instead have this kind
of form where they where they break and
they produce uh uh you know
um
uh
bubbles and things like that
so and and spray and so on
so so in any case there are uh now if
you ask the question why is the sort of
why is it complicated why is the surface
of the ocean complicated well it's
because there are interactions between
these different trains of waves first of
all the storm can have a complicated
form second of all when you produce
trains of waves they can interact in
complicated ways where they don't just
pass through each other sometimes if
you'll see a bunch of waves you know if
you if you drop one
uh one stone in water one place another
stone another place you'll get these
circular waves that come out and if the
waves are are small enough you'll
typically see just simple interaction
between those waves um where you get
sort of the the waves adding in some
places subtracting and others and so on
um but when the waves are bigger you'll
have more complicated interactions
between the waves and it won't be the
case that you can just sort of add up
the the heights of the water from those
two waves
and i think that's that's part of why
the sort of there's there's complicated
behavior in front of these ocean waves
that in general there's a certain sort
of spectrum of wave heights that exists
in the in the ocean
um
and when people design boats for example
they're saying what's the chance
there'll be such a big wave that it will
you know capsize the boat or something
like this
and uh uh there's it's known that
there's a sort of a power law
distribution of sizes of waves
and so one can get an estimate of of
make sure making sure that probability
is is small enough i mean on on the deep
ocean there's you know there's the swell
which is the sort of undulating um uh
you know this surface undulation of the
of the water i mean there are other
things that happen like tsunamis for
example if there's an earthquake under
the ocean there'll be sort of the the
bottom of the ocean will move you'll get
one of these deep water waves but you'll
get this this sort of big big uh you'll
get a bunch of water that's being that's
moves across the ocean and tsunamis can
can propagate across will propagate
across a whole ocean
when they're in the deep deep ocean they
typically don't have a very big effect
on the on the uh on the sort of height
of the water there but they're very long
and big and and so the total amount of
water that's in tsunami can be extremely
large even though it might only be you
know a fraction of an inch in in
difference of of height there but then
when the when the tsunami gets towards
land it's kind of bad news because
there's just a huge pile of water that's
coming towards the land and it bunches
up and it ends up being this giant wall
of water that can be you know hundreds
of feet high and things like that
and it's it's um uh that's something
where these days while in the pacific
ocean for a while they've been tsunami
early warning systems actually they
happen to be built originally i think
with modeling using our our uh software
uh technology um but in any case the the
the sort of an early warning system for
tsunamis where there are where there are
detectors of small waves in the ocean
um there weren't in the indian ocean uh
such such early warning systems what was
it um
oh gosh how long ago was it like 15
years ago there was a big tsunami that
sort of went all the way across the
indian ocean that caused all kinds of
trouble um and uh
uh that that's an example of a deep
water uh deep water ocean waves
all right let's see
so many questions here i should get
faster at answering these um
uh
there's a question from brady what are
neutrinos for why do they exist if they
don't interact with anything could
aliens have a purpose for them well i
don't think we know why neutrinos exist
just like we don't know why electrons
exist
or why muons which are kind of a heavier
version of electrons 206 times heavier
than electrons exist
there are actually three kinds of
so-called leptons things like electrons
that
behave as electrons do they interact
with they have electric charge
but they don't
interact directly through strong
uh
strong nuclear force through quantum
chromodynamics they can't get bound
inside a nucleus that's only protons and
neutrons um
electrons have electromagnetic
charge they also have a weak charge that
um
uh is related to
uh their effect in in uh well
in weak interactions which are
associated with things like beta decay
we'll talk about that in a moment um the
but so electrons
uh have a certain mass about 1800 times
less than the mass of a proton
uh there are muons that have a mass 206
times the mass of the electron
there are things called tau leptons that
have a mass about 3 000 times the mass
of the electron nobody knows why muons
and tau leptons exist
um they kind of go along with
strange and charm quarks and top and
bottom corks but nobody knows why there
are those extra generations of of
particles
so
we don't know why those things exist but
along with the electron there is a thing
called the electron neutrino
and
the first place that was observed was in
nuclear beta decay
where
for example well typically nuclei that
have too many neutrons in them will
decay
and the neutrons in one of the neutrons
in the nucleus will kind of explode and
produce a proton an electron and
something else
and the something else is an
anti-neutrino
and neutrino is a kind of particle like
electrons like quarks like other kinds
of things just a kind of particle but it
happens to have no electric charge
um and it has no
uh nuclear charge either no strong
nuclear charge either
so it's it's a thing that doesn't
interact it doesn't interact
electromagnetically and so that means
that it doesn't interact very much at
all it will go through you know you
shoot a neutrino at a
a
concrete block and if it's a low enough
energy neutrino it'll just go straight
through the concrete block in fact
neutrinos go straight through the earth
there are lots of neutrinos coming from
the sun and most of them just go
straight through the earth
now it's a little bit strange because
many particles
when they're more energetic they're less
likely to interact with something but
neutrinos go at least for for many
energy levels um go the opposite way
the probability that a neutrino
interacts increases like the square of
its energy
and the the reasons for that a little
bit like i could explain but let me not
digress onto why that happens
um
but
basically neutrinos so if you have a
higher energy neutrino it has a higher
chance to interact
and um neutrinos are only detected by
seeing
it's hard to that people don't know how
to directly detect a neutrino the only
way to detect a neutrino is to see that
it hits another particle and you see
that other particle it interacts with
another particle and uh and does
something so for example a typical thing
would be neutrino
hits um
something
and produces an electron and you can see
the electron because the electron has
electromagnetic effects you can detect
it by its electromagnetic
it's
essentially electrical effects
um
but neutrinos don't work that way
so neutrinos are
kind of
they're produced by nuclear reactions
they're produced by nuclear beta decay
whenever there's sort of an excess of
neutrons you eventually produce
neutrinos then you if you could separate
a neutron from a nucleus neutrons are
rather stable they last about 15 minutes
on average um but eventually they'll
they'll sort of decay into protons
electrons and anti-neutrinos
again from the sun where there are
nuclear reactions happening there's a
big stream of neutrinos from any nuclear
reactor there are there are neutrinos
produced so for example the neutrinos
from nuclear reactors
are
fairly energetic neutrinos so they're a
little bit easier to detect or many of
them are fairly energetic neutrinos and
so people talk about you know if you
want to tell whether a nuclear reactor
is running you can you know put a van
nearby that has something which detects
the neutrinos and you can tell that
there's a nuclear reactor running there
so for example i think i may have told
the story before but sometime in the
1980s
one of the things that um was
experienced of mine
was well let me let me explain that
nuclear submarines work by having
nuclear reactors in them and those
nuclear reactors can
can power submarines for for years
without them having to refuel so those
submarines can just go into the deep
ocean and hang out there and nobody
knows where they are and if the
submarines have lots of missiles that
they can launch and so on it's like
nobody knows where those missiles are
and they could you know if if uh if
everything
uh sort of goes bad the the uh the
submarine is still there and it's able
to launch its missiles at least if it
can have somebody tell it to do that
um so
the point of having all these submarines
hanging out in the deep ocean is nobody
knows where they are and uh they can
just sort of hang out and and not be
destroyed if people come and attack
other things on land and so on well that
works just fine so long as it's really
true you don't know where the submarines
are but the submarines have nuclear
reactors in them and their nuclear
reactors produce neutrinos
and if you could detect neutrinos easily
you could tell where the nuclear
submarines are
so i was interested in
neutrino detection actually particularly
from the early universe
back in the 1980s
and i was trying to figure out is there
a way to efficiently detect neutrinos
most things can't do that one of the
reasons it's possible to detect
electromagnetic radiation radio waves
and so on is that you can so-called
coherently detect it if you have a whole
bunch of atoms that are being better and
the radio wave goes through all those
atoms sort of all the electrons in those
atoms kind of move in in in a in a
synchronous way in a coherent way and
they have an effect that if you have n
atoms it's about n squared effect on all
those atoms and that that means when you
have lots of atoms you can kind of
detect the effect of the electromagnetic
wave the radio wave for example with
neutrinos in the most obvious way that
neutrinos interact with things you don't
have such an effect so if you have n
atoms you only have n times the effect
from the neutrinos coming through not n
square
but i thought maybe there was a way to
get an n squared effect
by using this uh
well the so-called a phase of liquid
helium 3 which is a very strange
substance that has various a strange
kind of superfluid behavior so i thought
maybe
there was a way to detect neutrinos
coherently and therefore make a pretty
good neutrino detector something which
would actually notice the presence of
neutrinos in ways that normal
neutrino detectors would not
and so if one could do that you could
have a satellite that would have all
this weird
you know helium-3 liquid helium-3 in it
and
carefully lined up magnetically and all
kinds of other things and it would be a
detector of neutrino of streams of
neutrinos from the earth in particular
it would show up the nuclear submarines
would show up as hot spots
in the oceans of the earth where there
were lots of neutrinos being produced
well the difficulty as a practical
matter was in the 1980s in the middle of
the cold war um
uh the uh
you know what would happen if if
somebody suddenly says oh by the way
there's this way to detect where all the
nuclear submarines are this is a
a weird sort of geopolitical thing to
have happen and i was very you know
because i thought i'd figured out
something about the science of how this
might work and it's like what do you do
with information like that um at that
kind of time in history and so i was
actually it was one of those cases where
uh i was very happy that that the
science didn't work out
uh the way that it seemed like it was
working out and it turns out that method
of detecting neutrinos won't work or at
least it doesn't work in at a practical
level and so no you couldn't detect
where all the nuclear submarines were so
that was a that was a good thing as far
as i was concerned at the time
but people have thought about you know
when the neutrinos that streamed through
the earth maybe you could essentially
x-ray the earth with neutrinos you could
look for you know deposits of minerals
in the earth and things like that by
looking at the absorption of neutrinos
as they go in different directions
through the earth but that's some uh
that's kind of a little bit of the story
of neutrinos there are actually three
different kinds of neutrinos that we
know actually six all together the
neutrino associated with the electron
neutrino associated with the muon the
neutrino associated with the tau lepton
and their anti-versions they're
anti-particle versions also and those
neutrinos have a very small well it's a
little bit of a complicated thing they
have a very tiny mass
and they actually mix so electron
neutrinos essentially turn into muon
neutrinos at a small rate and so on and
that's still a little bit not completely
worked out how that exactly
is set up but that's the basic idea
and so a question
would be
neutrinos by the way are sufficiently
low mass that they more or less travel
at the speed of light if they were of
zero mass they would travel exactly at
the speed of light but they travel more
or less at the speed of light
and so for example if there's a
supernova
explosion you expect a burst of
neutrinos at more or less the same time
that you get a burst of of light from
the um from the explosion now the
question was asked here uh could aliens
have a purpose for neutrinos yeah well i
think this whole question of what aliens
are like is a complicated thing but you
know could one do in principle neutrino
astronomy could one observe kind of sort
of neutrino things going on in the
universe eventually yes we'll presumably
be able to do that just like we can
observe gravitational waves but it takes
a very big detector to observe the very
small effect of gravitational waves and
we only tend to observe gravitational
waves when there's a big burst of them
from for example a merger of two black
holes which releases an amount of energy
and gravitational waves that's like
converting the whole of the sun into
energy in a matter of a second or so so
a huge amount of energy that we can
detect from essentially anywhere in the
universe with the gravitational wave
detectors that we have now that are a
few miles long and so on um presumably
one day it will be possible to detect
neutrino bursts in the same way from
from violent events like supernovas
although the total amount of of energy
released in neutrinos i think is quite
small compared to the amount of energy
released in gravitational waves in a
black hole merger um but still that's
that's the kind of thing one can expect
to have have happened there
um
so there's a question here from rbs
didn't neutrinos cause hardware failure
in airplanes no absolutely not
um the neutrinos have an absolutely
infinitesimally tiny effect instead of
world affairs there are cosmic rays that
are that come from the sun is spewing
out all kinds of things but it spews out
light it also spews out protons that are
uh that are
on average have a have an energy um that
makes them well that they have a
an energy that's about equal to their
rest mass one gev um come from the sun
and those stream towards the earth
um many of them are uh they sort of are
caught by the magnetic field of the
earth they tend to spiral in towards the
poles which is what leads to the auroras
and things like that as those interact
with the with the molecules in the upper
atmosphere of the earth um atoms rather
in the upper atmosphere of the earth
um
the uh
then then but um no the the cosmic rays
are
in
at at high altitudes cosmic rays are
mostly protons
um at lower altitudes when when they've
had to go through more of the atmosphere
they're mostly muons um and those those
sort of survive more to the surface i
have to say i i have this little
particle detector that somebody gave me
that's a thing that images particle
tracks um finally it's possible to have
sort of a
a home version of such a thing that um
you can just plug into your computer and
i have this and it it's been sitting
connected to my computer and it it it
shows a cosmic ray muon going through it
maybe
oh i don't know
a couple of times a minute at
more or less sea level where i live
but i decided to take it on a plane a
little while ago
and at the altitude of the plane you
know whatever it was 36 000 feet or
something the thing was just going crazy
um it was uh it was showing you know
cosmic rays going through it all the
time there's a lot more primary protons
it had these weird little v's but i
think of strange particle production um
from cosmic rays although i really need
to check that um that uh so it's really
a big effect on on difference in the way
and the level of cosmic rays at the
altitude of a plane um uh you know let's
say uh what is it um
uh tennis miles
um up is that right
then um
uh
than um in uh uh then at sea level and
so on
let's see maybe one or two more uh
okay the question if if technology could
produce a small practical neutrino
metronome detector would it be useful to
send messages with them sure
um just as it is
with electromagnetic radiation i mean i
mentioned submarines
and the problem with communicating with
submarines is water absorbs
uh things like radio waves and so on
mostly but if you have a sufficiently
long wavelength radio wave
a wavelength of miles long radio wave
it's still possible to detect those even
through the ocean those go through the
ocean they go through the whole earth
actually
sufficiently low
uh
low frequency long wavelength radio
waves can can get through lots of things
and so so submarines tend to have these
giant mile long antennas but they trail
behind them for detecting those kinds of
um
very extra low frequency elf
radio waves i think it's the case i
don't know if it's still true i think
it's true that i think it's wisconsin
there's a giant antenna that's a many
many many tens of miles long antenna
that is used to send signals to
submarines um when you have
that long a wavelength you have a very
low frequency and so that means you can
only send signals at an incredibly slow
rate of you know one bit per second or
something um but it's still possible to
send those signals sort of anywhere on
the earth and neutrinos uh can have
uh can be
sort of get through rock and all those
kinds of things but they can exist
in principle you could if you had a way
to modulate a neutrino beam if you had a
way to sort of well actually it's easy
well if you had a way to to change the
intensity of the neutrino beam that
would be like amplitude modulated radio
you could probably send
you could send signals
at perfectly high data rates
even going through large chunks of rock
you know communicating with uh
to people in caves or whatever else you
want to do and yes that would work with
neutrinos and you could send them if you
could detect the neutrinos well enough
you could be you know uh streaming their
favorite video show or something the tv
show down to a cave so to speak and and
getting it to go through the rock and so
on if you could make a neutrino detector
that would work efficiently enough which
we don't currently know how to do
um
let's see
uh
it's a question here
oh boy let's see so many different
things here
um
there are questions
uh from vast will holograms as seen in
the iron man movies ever be available
for widespread use
uh so first of all what is a hologram
so
normally when we see things we see
things because
uh light
hits the thing
the photons of light
kind of essentially bounce off the thing
and get to our eye and we see those
photons
and so
normally we're just seeing photons
that
directly come from
it's kind of like goes from the light to
the object to our eye
but
things are actually in a sense more
subtle than that
because
light
doesn't just behave like little
particles of light like little photons
of particles of light it also behaves
like a wave
where you can have where essentially you
have well it's an electromagnetic wave
it's got intensities of electricity and
magnetism um that are on a very tiny
scale
that are going in a certain direction at
the speed of light and those
that that sort of the the you can think
of what you see from an object as being
kind of a front of waves from that
object that are where the where the
direction of those waves corresponds to
the direction you would say the photon
was going in but you can really think of
the light as being either a whole
collection of photons a whole collection
of sort of correlated photons
or as a wave that has sort of um uh in
high and low intensity uh electricity
and magnetism on a very tiny scale on a
scale that's like um uh 100 trillionth
of a one
one
well 10 billionth of a meter um
in in
in
in size
so
okay
so
when light gets to our eyes it is we can
think of it as all these photons getting
to our eyes or this wavefront of all
these little electromagnetic waves get
into our eyes
but one thing we can do
is to kind of form those waves as they
are when they get to our eyes
in some kind of special way that isn't
just having the light bounce of an
object and come to our eyes and what
holograms are doing
is to
have a way to
to sort of form the structure of the
light
in such a way that it is as if the light
came from objects in a certain way but
it's just forming those wavefronts of
light in such a way that when they get
to our eye
we'll we'll say well that must have come
from an object like this but it's just
the the wavefront was sort of specially
formed
and so in a hologram what you'll end up
with is something that
is something where you have uh something
like a mirror but it's a mirror that has
little sort of tiny
uh changes tiny sort of uh
um
tiny
sort of features on it
that
will
uh
um will affect
uh tiny features that are actually
at distances smaller than the wavelength
of light
um that will sort of form this wavefront
that um uh that we perceive
so
one of the things that hasn't yet been
possible
is to make
a device
that has that produces a hologram in
real time that actually has is like like
you know the the computer display
has uh little pieces of liquid crystal
or light emitting diodes
um that are little semiconductor devices
where every pixel on the screen
is being independently controlled by
putting voltage uh to it and that causes
uh photons to be emitted there
but the thing that that
is sort of a thing that one is working
towards is being able to have a
holographic display
in which
the um uh the the the um
uh those places where the light is being
produced are so close together that they
are smaller than the wavelength of light
and that means that one can sort of form
this this wavefront
that
of light in whatever way one chooses so
if one could have a real-time sort of a
holographic movie that was being
produced in real time so our display is
not producing just separately all those
pixels but all those different pixels
are producing things which are sort of
uh uh
are coherent pieces of light that are
all sort of forming this wavefront that
eventually gets to our eye well if we
can do that and we can do that in real
time then we can make
light which will appear to our eyes to
be coming from whatever we want it to be
coming from
so that would be an example that that's
how one would make something which is a
hologram and a hologram in a hologram
because we're sort of getting that
wavefront of light that could come from
anything it can appear to come from this
object in three dimensions as you move
your head you're seeing different parts
of those wavefronts and you're seeing
things from different angles and so on
you're seeing something that is uh sort
of just like
the uh the light that will be formed
coming from the from the object that
you're dealing with so so eventually it
will probably be possible to have uh
sort of a a display that operates down
at the level that where the features are
small in the wave length of light and so
you'll be able to have a as a real-time
hologram created so i would expect that
that will be a thing that will be
possible now now at some level you might
say who cares because
if you you know we
sense the depth of objects we sense the
distance objects are away more or less
from the fact that they look a little
different from our right eye and our
left eye and we're fusing those two
images together in our brains and that
as those images are fused they're
slightly different from the left eye and
right eye the further away an object is
the more the same the images will be
from the left eye and the right eye and
the closer the object is the more
different they'll be just because of the
angles that that the eyes make to the
object and so if we have a head-mounted
display or some other display you know
some some kind of glasses where where we
have slightly different images that
we're showing in two different eyes we
will still have the impression of having
um
of having something which is in uh which
has depth because we're kind of fooling
our eyes into thinking that
um
the uh uh the the slightly different
images and so we can we can sort of mock
up what um uh uh the depth of the object
that way and that's been a technology
that's existed with you know red and
green glasses or polarizing glasses
things like that forever
and these days in in head-mounted
displays and so on is a and for virtual
reality and such like is a standard kind
of technology the tricky thing there is
as you turn your head the image better
change
um and that's a tricky thing to achieve
and there tends to be lag in that which
leads people like me to get horribly
motion sick in in most existing virtual
reality systems and such like
um
let's see
uh
well maybe um
it's a question here from aaron
why do some foods like peanuts and
crustaceans cause deadly allergic
reactions
um while other people eat them daily
without harm
how many species have allergies
oh boy we're in a quite different topic
here okay what are allergic reactions
well
the thing
our immune system
is
uh
its purpose is
when something that isn't us gets into
us the immune system wants to attack it
and get rid of it
so for example
if bacteria bacterial cells infect us we
want to be able to tell our immune
system wants to be able to tell
when something is circulating in our
blood for example oh that's a bacterial
cell it's not something that came from
us we should attack it and get rid of
that bacterial cell
or when a cell has been infected by a
virus
we should be able to tell that's a cell
infected by a virus we don't like it
it's not something of us let's get rid
of it
so the immune system has a couple of
different parts the innate part and the
adaptive part the part of the relevance
here is the adaptive part
what happens is
there are it actually has two components
b cells and t cells antibodies and t
cell receptors um
the um
what happens is
uh how do you tell whether something is
a a piece of us or not
well let's assume everything is made of
proteins
which is
the case for organic material
um
the uh
proteins are
sequence of amino acids their chains of
amino acids
and each protein is specified by genomic
sequence sequence of base pairs where
triples of base pairs three base pairs
together to find an amino acid then you
chain those amino acids together to get
proteins and once you've trained those
amino acids together the proteins fold
up in complicated ways because some
amino acids uh attract each other some
repel each other it's a very complicated
thing to determine exactly into what
shape proteins will fold although it's a
problem that with modern machine
learning one seems to have a pretty good
idea of how that will work at least for
proteins that are at least somewhat
similar to the proteins that we actually
see in biology where we know we can sort
of train the machine learning system on
those kinds of proteins
so in any case you you have these
proteins they form into these
complicated shapes but more importantly
the proteins are made from sequences of
amino acids
okay
so now how does the immune system work
well the immune system generates let's
say the let's talk about the antibody
part of the immune system it has about
100 billion i think different kinds of
antibodies that it can make
each antibody is a small piece of
protein is a small sequence it's
actually part of a larger protein
so-called hypervariable region of
immunoglobulins of of um it's it's part
of of the um uh
a piece of our of antibodies for example
is a piece of protein that is randomly
generated so it generates i don't know
what it is length 9 or 12 i forget of
that order of the order 10 amino acids
that are sort of randomly generated so
every time our immune system produces an
antibody every well every time a b cell
in our immune system uh is made it will
be jet it will have a different
sequence there and so it will generate a
different answer an antibody with a
different sequence and there are about a
hundred billion different kinds of
different possible sequences so the way
our immune system works is it's
generating randomly generating 100
billion different kinds of of antibodies
but then what happens is when you have
an antigen
a a a thing that um
uh
is a foreign
thing an invader so to speak
that invader will have some protein in
it that protein will have all kinds of
sequences of amino acids in it
and
some sequence of amino acids inside the
protein
inside that antigen will match
one of the will will typically match
um
you know one or a few of those
antibodies from that collection of 100
billion different kinds of antibodies
and the way the immune system works is
as soon as an antibody
successfully binds to successfully
matches an antigen
that's noticed and more and more of
those kinds of antibodies are produced
and so
and that um and those antibodies what
the more and more of them that are
produced they kind of tag pieces of the
antigen and then the rest of the immune
system comes and attacks things that
have been tagged by antibodies but the
basic point is that uh what's happening
is
the the proteins um that are in anything
are being continually checked by the
immune system the immune system these
antibodies those hundred billion
different kinds of antibodies they're
continually kind of jostling up against
different kinds of cells and proteins
and so on that exist in us and they're
continually trying to make that match
and most of the time the match isn't
going to be made most of the time it's
like we don't care about that it's uh it
doesn't match you know i the the
particular antibody with a particular
amino acid sequence don't match this
particular thing move on let's go try
and check check and see if we match
something else
okay so this idea of matching things
uh with antibodies is sort of the basic
idea of the adaptive immune system but
there's sort of a an issue there which
is the adaptive immune system doesn't
want to go into action
on cells that are actually pieces of us
it wants to say oh that's a piece of us
i know what that is i don't have to
worry about that
move on only when i see an amino acid
sequence that isn't something that is a
piece of us
should i go and start attacking it
and so how does that work
well
when we're born
we start training
probably before we're born actually we
start training our immune system to say
these are things that are parts of us
and these are things that are not so our
our
we have
a you know
genome that's six billion base pairs
long
that means there are many many many
possible sequences of six or twelve or
whatever it is amino acids that that
occur in that giants in that giant
genome and that are made use of in the
proteins that exist in our bodies
and so each one of those is
is kind of um
uh
we can we can kind of look at each of
those sequences each of those little
blocks
of sequence
and we can say well
from the six billion base pairs that we
have there are zillions of sequences
that are that are that are sequences
that are represent us they don't
represent that foreign invader they
represent us
and so
we have to learn the ones that represent
us and in our early life we do that
the thymus gland in our and our chest is
is a is a big piece of of doing that of
sort of parading
um essentially what's happening is on
sort of parading uh
their cells being being ones noticing
which antibodies are uh
so
recognize things that are us
and then what happens is by the time
we're kind of teenagers and things
the we're we're done we're trained our
immune system is trained it knows what's
us and what's not us
well that's how it's supposed to work
but autoimmune diseases arise
because things like
you know asthma type 1 diabetes
uh
i don't know celiac disease
in the end
multiple sclerosis lots of other
diseases
they arise from autoimmunity that is the
immune system turning against the cells
of our own body
and that happens because well nobody
knows completely why it happens but the
the effect is that it isn't the case
that
when that we didn't correctly train our
adaptive immune system
uh actually it's more relevant uh
antibodies are kind of things that just
go mark cells for attack by other parts
of the immune system there are also t
cells that have these things called t
cell receptors a little bit like
antibodies t cell receptors directly
bind to cells and the t cells can then
kind of directly attack cells and that's
more what happens i think in in most
autoimmune diseases
but um in any case the t cell receptors
are trained in the same way the
antibodies are trained
and the so what happens in autoimmunity
is that the um
uh
one
one attacks
cells of one's own so to speak
now okay how do allergies work
um
what's happening there
well what's happening there is one's
getting a sort of excessive reaction
to a particular uh protein in some
antibody
antigen and i'm now
oh my gosh
uh
forgetting how that cascade works
of um oh yeah i i think
well so i think the question that was
was partly asked is why do people get
allergic to peanuts and and and
shellfish and things like this
and why are many more people that are
things like peanuts that are allergic to
other kinds of things and why are
certain people are allergic to that
and i think the basic answer is
that
uh
the immune system
well let's see
the
i mean what what's happening is that the
immune system is mounting too large a
response to that little piece of peanut
protein um far beyond what it should be
mounting
and it fails to
to uh stop mounting that that attack um
and
you know i think
the question of sort of how the immune
system stops attacking things is also a
complicated issue because as soon as you
generate all those antibodies or all
those t cells with particular t cell
receptors you're generating lots of
these cells and the question is those
cells have never been seen before or not
in large numbers because they have some
some weird sequence on them that that is
sort of the the the negative of the
sequence on the antigen and they again
you know why aren't those generating
themselves an immune response
well the there's a theory that says that
they actually are and that to every
antibody there's also an anti-antibody
that's generated an anti-antibody
anti-anti-antibody and so on and there's
a whole dynamic cascade this whole
network of interactions between
antibodies and anti-antibodies and so on
and that's maintained in some kind of
dynamic equilibrium and that's probably
what immune memory is associated with
and so
i actually don't know how this works off
hand i i'm
i certainly have known this in the past
sorry i've i've forgotten exactly how
this works
um the uh you know when there's sort of
an excessive reaction and when there's a
failure to mediate that reaction um i
actually i think i think it is to do
with i mean what what happens is t cells
interact with t cells that's a very
known thing and i think it's the the
mediation of um
uh
of those of of of t cells by other t
cells that is what causes their not to
be an excessive um immune reaction to a
thing and when that system doesn't work
quite right you end up getting this kind
of excessive immune reaction and you end
up getting
t cells that in many cases of these
autoimmune diseases
will go and start attacking uh cells
that are part of of uh of one's own body
but but i'm i'm um
um
i'm
i'm a little bit muddy on this i have to
i have to go look at those immunology
books again
um
the uh
um
uh
yeah there's a question from
asking do we know the mechanism behind
the training yeah i mean what basically
is happening is if they bind
that's noticed if they don't bind it's
not it's uh
you know so so in our early life
we see some of this binding happening
and that is that is detected although i
admit that isn't a full explanation
so i i'm not sure that that is fully
known i mean one of the things that is
just the most you know biology has
advanced a lot in the last two decades
and you know it used to be the case
people just said oh there are white
blood cells
but then people realize there are
different types of white blood cells
there are uh b cells that produce
antibodies there are t cells
there are uh cells with different
proteins on the surface you know cd8
positive t uh uh cells there are other
kinds of cells there are there's this
huge diversity of different kinds of of
cells associated with the immune system
and
you know what used to be just the simple
oh there are a couple of different times
i was looking at an immunology book
recently and there are pages and pages
and pages of different just a summary of
different kinds of cells that are known
to exist so it's a pretty complicated
thing and there are pathways that are
known particularly through these
substances called interleukins
which are sort of uh
molecules that sort of communicate
globally in the immune system um they're
what lead to uh sort of the triggering
of
reactions like inflammation and so on
and it's a it's a complicated thing and
uh i i'm i'm i'm muddy off hand about
exactly how that works and allergic
reactions i i think you're generating
uh
generating this cascade it's it produces
there are interleukins which are
associated with these which are produced
when these binding events happen and and
there's some cascade that is produced
there that leads to this sort of
excessive immune reaction that's
associated with allergy but there are
pieces of that that i'm i don't i'm not
sure about and you know one of the
things that that often happens in these
things is
you know i'm not sure about them you go
look in the books and it turns out well
actually nobody's sure about them
but i'm not i don't know if that's the
case i i don't know if if that's
something i should know or not
all right i think i have to wrap up in a
moment here um
and uh
um
there are quite a few questions here
related to
more related to our physics project and
more philosophical kinds of things
which maybe i can address a different
time
um
and
um
gosh
uh
yeah i don't think there's anything here
that looks looks easy to answer quickly
um
so well
thank you for all sorts of interesting
questions here
um and uh
uh
we i look forward to going on
next week and trying to answer some more
new questions and some more questions
that i didn't get to this week
so uh and i i remind people by the way
that we now have um
oh how many is it it's at least a
hundred i would think
um uh recorded versions of these
science and technology q a's
and they are beautifully
indexed using our um oh i'm being told
this is episode 99 okay so so um okay
well next time we get to go to triple
digits but um uh
the um
uh you will find these on uh
on my website
um and
they've been run through orphan language
and
nicely
the transcripts from these have been
ground up into words and there are word
clouds which give you some indication of
what was actually being talked about and
there also are questions in um in plain
text
um
that
are are there in those recordings so if
you're interested in something that um i
might have talked about another time i
encourage you to look at those things
they exist as podcasts and so on
um and uh
uh
yeah it's well it's it's fun to answer
these things thanks for asking all kinds
of interesting questions
and uh
see you again next week bye for now